before I got on the air I looked and saw
that a number of theme parks in Florida
are closing down as this storm
approaches what are we anticipating in
terms of the business of ekta storm
could have right now the estimates range
from about 25 billion to 37 billion
dollars worth of damage depending on how
the storm tracks and that's a that's a
really important point here is because
the storm is going to go right up the
coast of Florida like a buzz saw the
question is whether it stays a little
offshore whether it comes on shore and
that's going to mean billions of dollars
worth of damage either way so damage to
structures and so forth but what other
kinds of fallout in terms of damage I
mean airlines are going to have to
cancel flights right people are going to
be evacuated and are evacuated right
right right so you've already evacuated
this vacua shun hoarders out to about 2
million people from South Carolina into
Florida airlines have already cancelled
3 thousand flights both today and
tomorrow most of those flights of course
out of the Florida airports but a lot of
flights you know around the country get
tied up with the equipment as you guys
mentioned the theme parks of all closed
cruise lines have diverted about 19
ships so yeah it is an impact all the
way across the board we'll get the next
complete advisory from the National
Hurricane Center I believe at five
o'clock this evening eastern time I was
looking at the one from 11am and the
Hurricanes that are not mincing words
here calling this storm extremely
dangerous what are they expecting in
terms of forecasting where it might go
we see it approaching Florida any sense
of what's going to happen next well you
see the storm is going to come into the
coast of Florida sometime overnight
probably early very early tomorrow
morning and the question is you know
does it actually touch the coast or not
and you know this is this is the
sixty-four-thousand-dollar question or
64 billion dollar question the area
where the hurricane-force winds is about
60 miles from the center so a little bit
offshore and it misses a little bit
closer to shore and the numbers are just
going to go up astronomically so you
know once we get past 24 billion dollars
we've cracked the top ten of the most
expensive storms and record in the
United States yeah I'm insurers are
definite
be down today as a result Norwich and
many of the other injuries that ensure
structure is in Florida bring us back to
the last major storm that hit Florida
and what it costs the state the last
major storm was Wilma in 10 years ago
exactly our 11 years ago excuse me it
was October 2005 and that was the year
when there are record 28 storms in the
Atlantic Ocean and also what everybody
remembers most is Katrina which you know
was in the hundreds of billions of
dollars you know Matthew is not going to
get to that level obviously because it's
it's just not the same kind of storm and
it's not coming in at the same angle
that some of these other past storms
such as Andrew did this is this is
ignore of a glancing blow as opposed to
a stab to the heart I'm real quick here
tropical storm nicole also in the
Atlantic what kind of role could that
play here is there any sense they could
maybe interact with each other over
these i'm not really i'm nicole actually
was upgraded to a hurricane just a few
minutes before i came on air here
usually what will happen in a case like
this is the larger storm will actually
eat the smallest storm but they're far
enough apart right now that nothing's
going to happen the coal is going to
spin around in circles Salta Bermuda and
won't be a threat to anyone